good morning and welcome I'm John
cotesworth Provost of the University the
university's chief academic officer
welcome to the 2013 columbia world
leaders forum this morning
our guest is armando emilio busa
president of the Republic of Mozambique
the title of his address to us will be
poverty and inclusive development in
Mozambique the seven million as a new
paradigm for socio-economic development
president abusin welcome to Columbia
University and thank you for being with
us here today I would also like to
acknowledge the presence of a number of
distinguished ministers ambassadors and
other members of the Mozambique
delegation who are here in front a warm
Colombia welcome to you all
as we are in the midst of another round
of visits by foreign dignitaries a
schedule that by design coincides with
the UN General Assembly's September
meeting in New York I want to note what
a remarkable opportunity Colombia's
world leaders forum has become for our
entire academic community this is an
experience that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate in any other
city or any other university in the
world Colombia has always been among the
most international of institutions in
the most global of American cities with
a large and growing percentage of our
students and faculty drawn from other
nations our academic mission demands a
global perspective and discussions like
the one we are about to have today are a
cornerstone of this pursuit Mozambique
once a Portuguese colony achieved its
independence in 1975 at that time the
nation was battered by economic
mismanagement and famine and promptly
became the battleground for one of
Africa's most devastating civil wars
progress has come slowly and in stages
in 1992 the long and violent civil war
reached its conclusion with the two
warring armies Frelimo and rana mo
transformed into political parties over
the past two decades the country has
made real progress and economic
development with foreign investors
showing interest in Mozambique's wealth
of natural resources untapped oil and
gas reserves and coal and titanium are
growing sources of revenue Mozambique is
soon expected to become one of the
world's largest exporters of coking and
thermal coal and also liquefied natural
gas yet despite being one of the fastest
growing African economies poverty
remains widespread throughout the nation
with half the population living on a
subsistence wage mozambique's economic
progress has not insulated the country
from a series of environmental blows
that have aggregated poverty levels
particularly in rural areas in 2000 and
again in 2001 Mozambique was hit by
floods that affected roughly one-quarter
of the population and destroyed much of
the country's infrastructure a year
later in 2002 the flooding was followed
by severe droughts in the past 18 months
political arrests and a surge of in
violence has revisited the country
raising the specter of a return to the
armed conflict that the leaders and
people of Mozambique fervently hope as
part of their past these are the
familiar and difficult tensions
confronting development nations economic
growth not yet strong enough to end
persistence poverty enhanced
infrastructure undermined by devastated
the devastation of natural disaster and
resolution of civil war followed by
continued unrest and ethnic conflict a
businessman who made his fortune in
energy energy and transportation
President Musa has made a priority of
winning the battle against poverty he
became the country's third ever
president in February 2005 succeeding
Mozambique's longtime leader Hakim
and he's the first man to enter the most
imminent presidency without non-marxist
party program and ideology campaigning
in a platform of economic growth through
greater foreign investment he won a
second term in office
in October 2009 I'm now very pleased to
welcome president Armando Emilio Musa to
the stage to discuss poverty and
development in Mozambique thank you
I am so pleased to be here I had heard a
lot of very impressive and good things
but Columbia University as we have
students that have fun pass through here
but also we also have done in Mozambique
research with your professors in various
areas so we can consider Columbia
University as a partner to development
in Mozambique so this is unique
opportunity for me and first one to
address you and present some of our
ideas on development of course we are
not going to cover all areas of interest
in development we are going only to
touch upon one aspect which for us is
very impressive but it's not the only
one if one went to understand what is
going on and was a big in terms of drop
meant but is the one that is present in
the whole of Mozambique and society in
particular in rural areas from two years
ago this program started also develop
development in urban areas in cities so
it is a great honor for us to stand on
this platform and address such a
distinguished audience of scholars and
students in this equally renown
institution of excellence whose research
and graduates make positive impact
across the world we will this way
understand how privileged
Phil to be amongst you or today to share
experience accumulated for over eight
years now since we took the decision to
allocate seven million metric eyes it is
about 250,000 American dollars every
year to each of our 128 digits for food
production and job generation and the
2.5 million medicals
about 80 thousand American dollars for
local public infrastructures the
question that begs to be asked is
whether this is not the way to go if we
want to the poor himself or herself to
have the opportunity to participate in
what he or she perceives to be poverty
and have access to means at individual
level as is the case for the loan from 7
million and at a community level with
the resource to 2.5 million we
understand here to share this experience
we stand here to share this experience
because we know that well of scholarship
and research is a world of thinkers a
world of men and women who keep pushing
the boundaries of creativity and
knowledge beyond imaginations to address
practical challenges for the benefit of
humankind ladies and gentlemen the fight
against poverty has gained international
prominence for a few decades now this
recognition arises from the fact that
international peace and security cannot
be ensured in an increasingly
interdependent planet with on one hand
versus
of prosperity and on the other a sea of
abject human deprivation which cannot be
justified and defended by moral argument
or by natural or artificial barriers or
even by force we are only aware that
under such world with imbalances the
affluent countries would eventually be
confronted by a massive number of
refugees trying to escape from different
manifestations of poverty those unable
to escape could become breeding ground
for those who are more than ready to
engage in the desert disruption of world
peace and security poverty on a global
scale has been described and rightly so
is the ultimate systemic threat to
global peace and security the
international community has recognized
the fact that tackling human deprivation
on a global scale is not only a
humanitarian act of charity or
solidarity but an effective investment
for a more harmonious stable and
prosperous world the adoption of the
Millennium Development Goals in 2000
further stressed the growing consensus
on a global scale that human poverty
represents a challenge that can only be
addressed effectively through the
collective efforts of the entire family
of nations of the world we are pleased
to note that the Rio +20 summit adopted
the process that will facilitate the
conception of the sustainable
development goals and it is our hope
that they carry forward and take on the
momentum generated by the legacy of
the Menominee Development Goals when the
implementation comes to a close in 2015
the international community is called
upon to honor the commitments assumed in
2000 aware of the fact that even if we
had achieved to all the goals we agreed
to meet at the Millennium summit we
would be talking about minimum
development goals not maximum
development goals because despite the
games the majority of the population of
the world would remain trapped in a
vicious cycle of poverty which
reproduces itself into the next
generations and into perpetuity blocking
the prospects of social mobility we will
not bring to your attention the views
and dimensions of poverty because being
a school international of international
public affairs in the Faculty of
economics you deal with these pertinent
issues on a regular basis but the same
by the same token we do not need to
remind our audience about the fact that
despite the scholarly and reach debates
there is no consensus among academics
themselves and even within regional
international organizations on the best
definition to capture the essence of
poverty in all its dimensions in
addition we often come across
organization with within reach we see
the tragedy of how the definition of
poverty has evolved over the years and
how specific definitions at least
implicitly elicit elicited specific
response to be deployed to address the
perceived definition of poverty from a
programmatic point of view we are
proposing an interaction between the
top-down and the bottom-up approaches so
that we give the poor the freedom
the means and responsibilities to define
and act on what he or she perceives to
be poverty within the parameters defined
at the top ladies and gentlemen in the
fight against poverty in Mozambique we
depart from the standpoint that we are
dealing with a multi-dimensional
phenomenon and that it's for it's fight
must be an agenda driven by all spheres
and segments of society with each
individual and institution playing the
expected role this builds self-esteem
local capacity and more importantly
sustainability open and frank debate
with various sectors of our society and
these among themselves helped to
entrench the sense of local ownership
and responsibility for the results at
the center of this process lies the
decentralization fest decentralization
fest of powers and of decision-making
processes on a number of issues secondly
there is a sterilization of human
resources and finally the digitalization
of financial resources to implement
decisions today as a result to have more
qualified civil servants working in the
districts and more and more decisions
being taken by the district
administrators and more and more
resources available locally informed by
the fact that poverty is a complex
multi-dimensional issue against was
fight every one of us has a role to play
having learned from the processes of the
centralization we have embarked on and
inspired by our own desire
to have the poor play a most significant
role in breaking the shackles of poverty
we decided back in 2006 to allocate to
each of our 128 districts financial
resources broadly aimed at food
production and job creation we mean
broadly because we wanted the grassroots
to have some latitude in defining and
acting on what would be their priorities
in the context of what has been decided
above by the central organs of the state
this decision emerged as a window
opportunity for our compatriots in rural
areas to have access to credit in order
to finance their business ideas
these are Mozambicans from humble social
strata who would never have dreamed of
bringing their business projects to
fruition because they do not have any
guarantees formally demanded by the
financial institutions as collateral to
grant credit because they are viewed as
high risk baraz in 2011 this fund was
extended to cover the urban areas as
well despite the substantial increase of
the budget allocation to each district
this fund is still known by the original
designation which made it a household
subject 7 million the increased means
that all these days receive more than 7
million for example in 2013 the
districts of mokuba in the bay as a
central part of mozambique sousou lenga
in mineka and shy-shy
in gaza have doubled that amount this
increase was made on the basis of an
index which seeks to import
create more objective criteria in the
location of these resources the index is
comprised of the following items and his
receipts respective weight in
percentages the number of inhabitants
35% poverty incidence 30% territorial
area 20% and revenue collection capacity
15% we now turn to the structures the
management and decision-making process
of who is to benefit is taken by the
local authorities with active
participation of the consultative
concerns these are also instrumental in
deciding on what projects are to be
approved and how much is to be allocated
the consultative council is a structure
that works at the levels of the locality
administrative post and district and
from this list we go to the province
there is another body that does that
which is the Provincial Assembly the
election of the members of the
consultative council starts exactly at
the grassroots level at the locality to
be precise and moves all the way up to
the district level does individuals with
perceived procedure and integrity I
elected in the locally in locality to
begin the activities of the consultative
council of the locality then they join
the members of the consultative councils
of other localities to elect or be
elected as members of the consultative
council of the administrative post once
this process is concluded
those elected
this body join the members of the
conservative councils of the
administrative posts to elected or to
elect or be elected as members of the
district consultative council usually at
least 30% of the members of a constable
can serve his respect the agenda code
that was at least 30% would be there one
day has Mozambique more than 50% of
women then we are going to reach also
that position there for those perceived
to be to have prestige in integrity
elect and I elected by others who have
come to do these fora because I seen to
share the same moral values and ethics
having provide you with the structure in
processes or the management of the 7
million we now turn to the process
leading to the approval of the
individual projects this process follows
the same system as that to have of how
the organs are constituted it starts
from the locality until it reaches the
district and the members of the
consultative councils in various levels
assume the role of collective moral
guarantors of the loan because they are
formally the body entrusted with
awarding credit to deserving projects it
is a process that takes into account the
conduct and the reputation of prospect
borrowers and the potential of the
project for job generation of food
production it is to be noted that the
process of reaching a decision and
consensus on which projects are to be
left out and which are to be funded with
these limited resources is in itself
and exercise of democracy and of
building the sense of citizenship and
belonging bill - built in to defend is
the concept of paying back what has been
borrowed we review feeding into the
revolving fund that will bring more and
more autonomy and resources under the
management of the local authorities and
cons the consultative councils to deal
with poverty at individual level there
have been constraints in this record but
both the consultative council and the
local administrative authorities have
taken these as challenges which they are
addressing head-on in the next in the
context of the interactions who are
engaged in with the local communities
and what we call open and inclusive
presidency which we will touch upon
later we decided that it was also time
for the local communities to have a say
in the definition and action on what
they perceive to be poverty at community
level as a result and persuaded by the
role of positive councils the role they
play in deciding and in providing
defense and the role the individuals
assuming in tackling poverty we decided
in 2009 to allocate
another fund called 2.5 million medicals
about 800 thousand American dollars to
each of 128 districts for public
infrastructure visit there again the
decision on how and which
infrastructures are to be the priority
each year is left to the local
administrative authorities and to the
consultative council to take based on
the same criteria we outlined for the 7
million or the
it's received more than 2.5 million
infrastructures for example MoMA and
Moog Evolis in nampula has reached 20
million village in Zambezi 23 million
Monica in Monica Monica district in
Monica province 24 million and villain
colony Ambani 16 1 6 million we note on
ladies and gentlemen to the impact of
both the 7 million and 2.5 million from
dia we inaugurated as the third
president of Mozambique in 2005 we
decided to expand the experience of
interacting and living with our people
like fish and water in the water which
we developed as a liberation movement
during the 13 1 3 years of struggle 2190
62 and 174 9 for our independence from
the Portuguese colonial rule this is an
experience which was used by our
predecessor in the process of
interacting with our people and in the
building of our sovereign nation state
who have taken kyouto from that
experience to launch in 2005 what has
come to be called open and inclusive
presidency by presidencia Alberta in
Kosovo a mechanism that is also drawing
new horizons in good governance and its
Intendant pillars that is participation
consensus building integrity property
accountability transparency and
inclusion which rests on spaces for
vulnerable groups open and inclusive
president presidency which is replicated
at other levels of our government takes
us every year
for an average cumulative period of two
months since 2005 to visit districts
administrative posts and locality after
the arrival which is marked by a tree
planting ceremony
which is very important for us to show
our respect and need to protect the
environment in the context and this
planting love that tree ceremony is in
the context of what it's in the context
of our initiative which is one pupil one
tree per year and one village leader one
new forest we proceed to a valley which
is graced with prayers and performances
of local cultural groups both of which
enhance their sense of pride in their
culture and denominations and above all
their sense of contributing to the
cultural diversity of their nation after
local population message has been read
out and the members of aggregation
introduce themselves with River our
message after which we invite 10 people
to come to the stage to speak out their
mind which means putting our government
to popular scrutiny because of time
constraints those who cannot make it to
the stage speak to the members of the
Leggett our delegation who record their
views which foam part of the body of our
boat the last part of the visit consists
of the joint meeting of local
authorities and consultative council
where the performance report
of the former is presented this is
followed by a debate of that report
which questions and comments coming from
the visiting delegation including those
arising from the just ended rally the
answers and comments and even questions
are offered first by the participants
residing in that locality who are not
members of the consultative councils but
they are there these are followed by
members of the consultative council who
are not members of the local government
the members of the local government
speak last the open and inclusive
residence give us an opportunity not
only to assess how the local
institutions work but also to witness
firsthand how our people are taking
advantage of the latitude given to them
by the government to define and to act
upon what they perceive as poverty with
results that are changing their lives
and in the process changing the image of
their communities it is worth mentioning
that when we visit them in their places
of production or when we speak in our
rallies from the stage on the basis of
first-come first-served and to the
members of our delegations as we have
indicated they display pride and a great
sense of ownership fairs are also
organized fairs are also organized at
places of the rallies to exhibit the
results of seven million and they are
also instances of those who come to
speak on stage who bring along they are
produced or artifacts of their own
making to display to us and to the crowd
attending the rally the visible increase
in agricultural production and crop
diversification in turn has an effect in
the diversification of the diet and
food and nutrition nutritional security
we have areas where in the past people
used to die of hunger but today the
inhabitants are requesting
agro-processing units facilitation of
trade for their surplus and expansion of
the banking network to invest their
savings there is also growth in the
artisanal industry and increased
dynamics in rural markets with much
greater monetary circulation in addition
to the afore mentioned advances there
are places where motorcycles used to be
a rare sight but today workshops to
repair them and shops to sell their
spare parts have been made viable by
increased number of these motorcycles
these are not only used for Asia but and
more importantly for carrying goods to
markets and for bringing inputs and add
a product to supply local markets today
there are guest houses in places where
such facilities would be unsinkable in
the past the challenge of sustainability
is ingrained not only in their greater
confidence that they can indeed change
their lives but also in the
diversification of the activities as far
as the 2.5 million is concerned we also
note with satisfaction that substantial
changes are occurring in both urban and
rural landscape apart from what is
conveyed to us through the message of
our people at the rallies and by
dividuals
who come to the stage to speak their
mind we have the opportunity to to visit
and to see for ourselves these changes
indeed we have come to see how the
number of public buildings and
residences for civil servants has
increased and my infrastructures to
facilitate development of agrarian
activities have been put in place this
is the case of small dams irrigation
systems
and dipping work thanks for Kato
similarly we see more boreholes market
infrastructures and more facilities in
the local health centers pushing this
initiative to new boundaries local
communities will add roads into their
decision-making portfolio as they are
acquiring suitable equipment for rural
road building and maintenance this
individually and community driven
advances brought about by the seven
million and by the 2.5 million
respectively complement and establish a
symbiotic relationship with the projects
that are planned and executed via the
central government which also helped to
change the local landscape these
resources are also to be seen in the
context of our policy of redistribution
for inclusive growth we will give you
some examples in 2004 we had 12
institutions of higher education in 2013
we have 45 in 2004 only 7% of our people
had access to electricity today we have
37% in 2004 we had 26 districts with a
financial institution that fuga fuga
figure rose to 33 this year
similarly the mobile phone network today
covers over 80 percent of the territory
of Mozambique and more roads and bridges
have been built which facilitate
communication travel and circulation of
people goods and services the provision
of social and economic infrastructures
which alongside the soft infrastructures
in the form of policies and institutions
that drive the
accept the reforms create an enable
environment for greater participation of
the private sector in the changing of
the landscape in rural areas ladies and
gentlemen as we translate in to
deliverable our policy of the
centralization we are also investing in
the capacity of our compatriots to be
able to define by themselves within the
provided latitudes what they perceived
to be poverty and act against it both at
individual level and at community level
hence the seven women represent an
important axis of the retribution
process the distribution process of
resources aimed at empowering the
poorest whose sustainable and viable
ideas would otherwise never have access
to the financial means through the
formal banking system on the other hand
this initiative brings about inclusion
of the poorest indices in the process of
work generation and therefore in the one
in the our national drive to Make
Poverty History in Mozambique this
segment of our people would otherwise
see their energies creativity and
innovative interpreter skills go to
waste
at a great cost to society at the same
time the 2.5 million came to provide
local capacity to fight what has been
identified as poverty at the community
level with the participation of the
community self the consultative council
emerged as mechanisms for community
participation a civil society
institution was collegial
decision-making process feed into local
development as they engage in this
process it draws them to them that
planning means defining priorities which
in turn means that some activities are
to be left out and cause a consensus has
to be built as to which activities are
to be chosen this is an important
process for entrenching democracy and
democratic values
despite to gain
we have obtained we are conscious that
these mechanisms will always remain work
in process requiring adjustments and
refinement to meet the set of goals we
have already outlined however one thing
is certain the 7 million and 2.5 million
are reshaping our view on the role the
poor should play to read themselves for
her selves himself or herself from the
trap of poverty we thank you very much
for your attention
but there I would like to thank the
president for sharing a challenging
topic issue with us how Mozambique is
addressing a problem that we need to
address not just the Mozambique but
worldwide the alleviation of poverty
he's underscored the obvious which is
complex but he made a number of points
before the question answers which I'd
like to highlight it clearly is a
humanitarian issue it's a moral issue
there's no question about that
but it's also using a vernacular that
some others may prefer I do not I like
tomorrow security
it's a sad case that countries that are
not more prosperous also insecure he
also raised something else which I think
is too often forgotten including in the
academic world confidence he wants to
raise the confidence of the people the
local ownership we need to believe in
people we need to also believe in poorer
people they frequently know better what
they need for today and for tomorrow we
may have the vision for the longer term
but they do know and they need to be
participating in the process because
it's their lives I think unfortunately
that is too often forgotten by many of
us so I thank the president for raising
those issues he's raised many others but
the local ownership the decentralization
to participation and a word of
confidence people need confidence they
have a right to confidence to have a
right to their dignity now I will open
it up to questions there are two mics on
each side the president has requested
that we ask for let's say four questions
and then he will address them and answer
them and so if you can line up the only
requirement is to state your name your
affiliation if it's Colombia what school
or if it's another affiliation please
identify
yourself so there are two mics and if
you could please just line up and like I
said we will take four questions at a
time and then the president will answer
so we'll start with the lone person on
the right hi Thank You mr. president for
coming my name is Amy Wong I'm a
Columbia College graduate and Columbia
Law School student I wanted to ask you
about foreign investment increasing
there hasn't south-south investment
investments from China and India for
example so how can that be regulated and
be changed to make it more beneficial to
the average person for the average
person especially those in poverty I'm a
junior at Columbia College studying
English literature in history write your
name my name is mystic Foster I'm from
from the meze province and the district
of a guru way in northern Mozambique
um my my questions related to South
South investment what is the role of
regional cooperation and especially
proposed free trade area through that
Southern African Development Community
going to play especially as transport
infrastructure and and and most weaken
ports come to play a larger economic
role hello my name is Tamika Jackson and
I am undergrad in the school of general
studies here at Columbia and I was
interested in you speaking more about
the district decision decision-making
and the gender circles and what kind of
education is occurring with the young
women who are going to participate in
these gender circles how far where the
education take them to be able to
participate outside
the district Gerald McClure I'm a
student at the School of International
Public Affairs I was working in
Mozambique this summer on a baseline
study in maloom bo I'm interested
mr.president and knowing what steps your
government is taking to avoid the same
fate of countries like Angola where the
resource curse has taken hold I know
that I'm a puto the cost of living has
already gone up exponentially what types
of steps is really ever been taking to
prevent that from happening in
Mozambique as well okay we'll take one
more hello my name is blessing tawang
well I am a graduate student in
sustainability management and my
question is along the same lines as far
as mining and any other extractive
processes what policies do you have in
place to make sure that that is
sustainable thank you thank you for your
questions I can see that some some of
you are coming from Mozambique and
coincidentally from the same province
Mulumba and guru a in the Meza in the
very very interesting areas in the
determinants in a way for our own
development so foreign investment we
create create we continue to create the
environment to attract as more investors
as possible both domestic and foreigners
China being one of them and in which
China awaitin mostly in areas like
building infrastructures and also in
agricultural development now we're
turning to also electricity production
to get of course with their partners for
for to produce hydro
hydro powered energy in this project we
give importance to the participation of
more and vamos and beacons but sometimes
we have a situation where we do not have
skilled Mozambicans for the specific
areas so it is the obligation and we
monitor that that they train on job but
at the same time that they have the
opportunity to learn from schools that
we have I will just link up with another
element since we have this gas and coal
we sell ourselves in a situation where
we do not have technical known knowledge
by our youngsters to a cantos type of
project so our universities including
Eduardo winter and the others today have
courses that address these issues of
hydrocarbons and others an American is
invested in vessels also involved in
that for example we have Anadarko and
and Eni which is the Italian Italian
hydrocarbon organization that has some
gas in Mozambique they are training and
supporting all universities and we hope
that as soon as possible we can have
specialized universities to do not only
mine but we'd also hydrocarbon as such
both gas and and coal has brought to us
a new challenge today which she has to
do with logistics how to take these gas
or how to take that call to ports
where they can be sold outside of course
we do not look only to that we're
looking also into industrialization of
the country let me use but of course we
need also to be in in the market as such
they two things complement each other do
not exclude each other that's why we
have a project and now a program to do
now to build more and more railways
leading to forts that existed like Vera
but it's same time to increase the
capacity of handling of door sports an
increasing capacity of transport of core
on roads railways but we are creating
also new ports in Nacala for a new port
is being built with an investment by a
private valet Mozambique which will end
or something like 40 million tons of
coal here but also a new Allen is me
expanded to be able to transport all
that coal and a new port also is being
planned to be built ins and as a
province which is closer to Moretz so
preparations are underway so that we can
find who can do that with private also
finals
education to own women as as the
possibility of their moving out of the /
districts or all our all our effort is
to keep our young men the seven seven
seven million and two point is to give
them jobs where they are as we have
today in all districts secondary schools
just to make a brief comparison during
the colonial period let's say forty
years ago we had in Mozambique less then
then then then twenty secondary schools
the whole country I'm exaggerating
probably ten around ten schools today in
all the 128 districts they are second
disclose all of them and now in the post
administrative that comes below we also
are having more and more secondary
schools and no Coco's we saw ourselves
making that mistake of giving education
but not orienting that education into
soft rock solving our problems so today
we encouraging and we are building more
and more of technical schools my dream
would be that in every district at least
we'll have one second of school want one
one one one one technical in the new
education
they they the problem the problem of
money of of controlling money we do it
through first from from legal point of
view and secondly through creating
institutions that can really control it
and our laws highly protective of of
using money only legally but one thing
is having something written that
protects another thing is to have
capacity to control so that why
strengthening of our institutions is one
of the big priorities of ours we when
when some some years ago we were
depending in terms of our budget
something like more than 50% from donor
community and credit and today we was
less than 40% because the capacity to
get revenue through our institutions
that is the Revenue Authority is
increasing they and that is a way of
doing it but that would continue to be a
challenge not only in more some vehicles
you know anywhere in the world but in
our case probably we are still young in
terms of organization with may shape
institutions that can avoid mistakes
that others may have made mining must be
sustainable I agree completely all our
activities must be sustainable
otherwise there was no use of doing that
and that's why we have joined in terms
of mining called that organization that
the transparence that have to declare
all revenues that coming from from the
mines not only to the government but
also to deceive a society which
participates and since the reports of
what is happening to make sure that that
is done but of course the responsible
social responsibility of those investing
also it's something that we are giving
priority to but in social social in
social responsibility one thing is to
receive something movor
is another thing is to have nomes
regulations that make sure that we know
what a company providing resources
should be doing and how these resources
are being managed with the participation
also of our government and of course a
loss in society I know you have many
more questions however the one freedom
he has not talked about his freedom from
schedulers and he also is not his own
master he is subject to schedulers so
unfortunately the schedulers have their
demands and we have Omo we have run over
so he has raised many issues but I hope
this is only the beginning of an
engagement with Colombia and maybe we
can work together on freedom from
schedulers in the future so I'd like to
thank the president for being with us
today and sharing his thoughts and also
his honesty about poverty alleviation is
a challenge it's complex it doesn't
happen overnight so I'd like to ask the
delegation to join us going out and if
everyone could just wait till we depart
the room thank you very much